black holes are one of the most exciting
and extreme predictions of general
relativity so they're a big departure of
Einstein's theory from what we know
about gravity from say the solar system
a really extreme place where not even
light can escape so the ultimate victory
of gravity over everything else soon
physics and Jason Dexter and 32 years
old I come from Seattle in the northwest
of the US and I moved to Germany a year
and a half ago and I study black holes
astronomer we see black holes either
through their gravity or through light
that's emitted by gas that falls into
black holes and so we can actually study
them in astronomy even over big parts of
the universe and we hope to use them
also to learn that about gravity and
test Einstein's theory as well Germany
is a great place to come to do science I
think first of all there's a very strong
group here that has a great track record
of studying the galactic center and
showing that there's a big black hole
there and then they're building this new
exciting instrument gravity that's one
of the things that's going to get us
this new information about gas close to
black holes
it was too good of an opportunity to
pass up against living in Munich and
working here it makes me aware of how
Americans are loud and talk a lot here
if we have interactions it's much more
common to me it seems that way that
people are comfortable sitting in sort
of silence or not speaking just to fill
silence and so I tried to listen more
and talk less and not feel the need to
say something just because nobody's
talking I appreciate the aspects of
quality of life here then it's very nice
to walk around Munich's a very nice safe
place I'm not strange anymore because I
don't own a car so in the u.s. even in
cities it's just sort of unusual to not
own a car everything is much more
pleasant and seemingly made for people
and not for cars which I personally
appreciate a lot I like walking around
in the parks and in the anguish ER
garden and I don't know the beer gardens
are very nice the ER is great mostly
getting outdoors is really great here
but in this line of work you don't often
really choose where to stay or how it
will work I really like doing
astrophysics so I would like to continue
doing that and that choice means that
choosing where to live is much more
difficult
you